so let's talk about Roseann for some
reason Roseann as I'm sure you her
you've heard has been canceled because
Roseann the person went on a bizarre
deranged tweet storm that included a
racist tweet and it was a really racist
tweet I mean actually racist
there's a definite boy who cried wolf
thing that goes on with racist claims
where everybody's accused of being
racist and everything is racist and so
on and so forth but in this case there's
there's a wolf there's a there's a real
wolf here because this was actually
racist Roseanne tweeted this was her
tweet Muslim Brotherhood and Planet of
the Apes had a baby BJ
as in DJ was the baby and BJ refers to
Valerie Jarrett who's Obama's former
White House adviser and she's a black
woman now some conservatives on Twitter
have really embarrassed themselves by
trying to defend Roseanne on the basis
that Valerie Jarrett is not actually
black and so it's not racist to say
she's from Planet of the Apes but she is
definitely actually black and I mean
I've even seen I've seen people passing
around photos of Valerie Jarrett where
she where her skin has been lightened in
the photo through Photoshop in order to
defend Roseanne I mean this is just it's
really pathetic she's not only is she a
black woman but she's clearly black
there's not it's I I'm no Rose I'm not a
Valerie Jarrett biographer okay what I
know very few things about her in fact
what I just said is everything I know
about her I know she was a former White
House adviser and she's a black woman
and I know that she's a black woman
because I've seen her and if you do
actually investigate her her lineage
you'll find that both of her parents
were black so she's and in fact she
apparently even has her maternal
grandfather was a prominent black
architect or something like that I
believe so she's definitely black and no
way around it Roseanne said that and
she's obviously black and Roseanne says
she's from Planet of the Apes and she
was also now to put this in fully in
context Valerie Jarrett was also born in
Iran so you've got a black woman born in
Iran and Roseanne says that she's the
love child of the Muslim Brotherhood and
Planet of the Apes that is super super
hyper racism on steroids that's that is
the if that's not a racist comment then
it is impossible to make a racist coven
racist comments don't exist if that is
not a racist comment I I don't know how
else to put it there's no justifying
that there's no claiming it's now raises
it is okay and
it it's not this is one thing people are
not playing a gotcha game with Roseann
where they're jumping on some innocent
comment and trying to make it no this is
she said that a black woman's from
Planet of the Apes and so you know just
don't say that it's it's a really easy
thing to not say right most of us can go
through our whole lives and never say
that a black person is from Planet of
the Apes it's a really easy thing to not
say and if you don't think it if you
don't think that way then you probably
would never say it and especially should
be easy as for Rosanna's or whatever 65
year old wealthy multi-millionaire
prominent woman who's getting paid
millions of dollars from from ABC to do
a show you know I think ABC expects her
to not go on a public forum and say
racist stuff and that's not a that's it
that's a pretty reasonable expectation
just don't do that don't say that why
would you say that you've got hundreds
of people that are relying on you for a
job think about all the people that work
on Roseanne and now they're out of a job
not because of ABC because of Roseanne
because she's mentally unbalanced and
selfish and so she can't control herself
you know this is her fault 100% the
firing makes a lot of sense I'm sorry
guys this is not a it's not a free
speech issue Roseanne is not a martyr
okay she's not being persecuted she
brought this entirely on herself 100%
roseann because she's loony put her
employers in a position where they had
to choose this is this is the position
that her employers rent they had to
choose between defending slash
minimizing her statements comparing a
black woman to the Planet of the Apes on
one hand they could do that and this is
a major company in the year 2018 reliant
on sponsors and advertisers and so
they're thinking they can get in that
corner okay and try to make that
argument that died on that hill or they
could just fire her
and they chose the latter and you know
something that's a perfectly sensible
thing to do and I'll tell you this if it
were my employee and I'm paying them
millions of dollars and then they go in
a public forum and say crap like that
I would definitely fire them I wouldn't
even have to think about it of course
you're gonna fire them it's not my
responsibility as an employer to defend
you on that it's your responsibility as
someone getting paid millions of dollars
by me to not embarrass me like that and
to not cause a PR nightmare where I
could lose millions of dollars it's your
responsibility to not do that and you
couldn't even fulfill it so get out of
here
you're done
any sensible businessperson would make
the same decision and I know you're
gonna say well shoot millions people
were watching her show she's got a good
you know what they're gonna find another
show that's gonna do fine and most of
the people that are saying they're gonna
boycott ABC and Disney they won't do it
they just won't they'll you know if
there's another show most of people
right now say I'm done with ABC
Roseanne's not on ABC yeah you know what
with if ABC has a show next week
announces a new show and you think it's
interesting you'll watch it everybody's
going oh just what you know people just
if people want to watch something
they're gonna watch it it doesn't matter
now
and and by the way just just to say one
thing I think this is important
it would be different I think it would
be different if if let's say Roseann had
made a comment like this a long time ago
she'd made a joke like this and somebody
went on a dirt digging expedition and
dug this up to try to destroy her and
they you know went sifting through and
they went through the effort to go find
this thing from a long time ago and use
it against her and let's say that were
to happen and then this is brought to
the forefront and Roseanne's embarrassed
and she apologizes that she says yeah
that was a long time ago I I regret it
you know I made jokes like that I've
grown since then I'm not that kind of
person anymore I'm you know I'm at all
I'm a 65 year old woman now this is
that's not who I am anymore
if that's how it had gone
then I would probably be on Roseanne
side I would say look you know you can't
people make mistakes is a long time ago
and and and she's moved on since then
she's grown so no I don't think you
should take her past sins and hang them
around her neck but that's not what
happened this is something she just said
yesterday publicly in front of everybody
and she said she's making excuses for it
now now she said she was on ambien and
that's why she said it so she has not
taken
she said it publicly yesterday and she
it won't even take ownership of it she
refused to take ownership she's saying
that she was on ambien and that's our
excuse so you know what can you do this
is you have no choice but to just fire
her now
I think this story serves or should
serve anyway
as a cautionary tale for conservatives
um
and to understand why let's back up for
a moment okay let's back up to the but
let's let's go back to the 90s okay to
understand
um
picture in the foot context so in the
90s Roseann was one of the most
left-wing sitcoms in the history of
American television if not probably the
most left-wing in fact at the time it
promoted abortion it promoted gay
marriage it was blatant in its agenda
ahead of its time in that regard now
it's not so
unusual to find shows that promote those
things of course but back then it was
unusual so Roseann was not oh not only a
leftist sitcom but it was a radically
leftist sitcom and it was ahead of the
curve in terms of its leftism so that's
the show then it ends and Roseanne the
person goes on to become a far left
political activist she runs for
president as a socialist
she's an avowed socialist she champions
left-wing causes she was so mad at
chick-fil-a because its CEO
supports traditional marriage that she
tweeted a few years ago when I quote
anyone anyone who eats crap filet well
she didn't use craps use the S word
so yeah anyone who eats chick-fil-a
deserves to get cancer anyone who eats
chick-fil-a is does it deserves to get
the cancer that is short to come from
eating antibiotic filled tortured
chickens for Christ
so she tweeted just to recap there okay
she tweeted that that the Christian
conservatives who eat chick-fil-a
deserve to get cancer and then when she
was criticized for this she lashed out
at the Christian liars who were
attacking her she never actually
apologized for the tweet and in fact
what she did is she backtracked and she
made an excuse and she later claimed
okay she later claimed that she she
wasn't saying that anyone deserves to
get cancer what she was trying to do was
she was trying to warn us of the of the
the negative health effects of eating
fast food she was trying to warn us of
the health impact of eating fast food
that's what she was claiming that tweet
was about so she has a pattern of not
only saying vile disgusting things but
of refusing to take ownership of them
and refusing to have the moral courage
to own them and to apologize for them
and instead coming up with lame
ridiculous excuses the kind of excuses
that a twelve-year-old would come up
with that's the pattern of behavior for
Roseanne that goes back years
and then there's a few years of this guy
so just remember by the way if you're a
Christian conservative and you and you
like chick-fil-a you support trishul
traditional marriage and you also love
Roseann just remember that she wants you
to get cancer that's what she said so
she thinks you should get cancer that's
her opinion about you
so I don't know I mean that
baby is a relevant point a few years of
this stuff continues and then during the
2016 campaign Roseanne randomly says
that she likes Trump of all the things
that she's rambling about nonsensically
that's one of the things that she
happens to say although her left-wing
convictions still remain intact
she likes Trump
and suddenly this woman who has spent a
career spewing far-left lunacy all over
the place and and promoting and
mainstreaming far-left
ideas this woman who has wished cancer
on Christian conservatives now becomes a
hero of conservatives simply because she
likes Trump
and then the new show was announced and
in the first episode of the new show
there's a storyline involving a
cross-dressing 9 year old
so there's no it's not like she has a
chance she's had a change of heart and
she's changed and she's grown and the
show's gonna be different now and
everything and and this what used to be
a far left show is now gonna be a
conservative Family Values show no it's
still far left it is still actually
ahead of its time and it's far left miss
cross-dressing nine-year-olds on a
family sitcom is still unusual
so again Roseanne is ahead of the curve
on on the Left ISM
but still conservatives some of them
anyway champion this show in spite of
the gross perverted sexual ization of
children all because Roseanne likes
Trump
that's it
that's all it takes every nothing else
matters she just likes Trump and some of
the people that have this attitude they
said well I've forgiven Roseann it's
it's forgiveness no it's not forgiveness
if she didn't like Trump you wouldn't be
saying any of the stuff you're saying
right now be honest don't tell me it's
because you've forgiven her it's because
she likes Travis the only reason
if everything else stayed the same with
Roseann but she didn't like Trump you'd
hate her you wouldn't you would be
watching the show you would support her
it's only because of the Trump thing is
that's the only reason that's it
so then that happens within roseanne
proceeds to say racist stuff so
you
what did conservatives achieve by
latching on to a celebrity who happened
to uh Terr one thing they agreed with
what did conservatives achieve nothing
I'm afraid this
they embarrassed themselves that's what
they achieved
they embarrassed themselves we are
embarrassed now and somehow you've got
this far left person
who says something racist and now
suddenly we have to take ownership of
that that's our thing now when it
shouldn't be this is a far left comedian
why is why is this our thing becomes our
thing because for some ridiculous reason
we latched on to her
and so we're embarrassed and that is
generally what happens when
conservatives you know with with
conservatives and they're desperate sad
pitiful celebrity infatuation this is
generally what happens whenever we cling
on to any famous person who says one
single thing we agree with we end up
looking stupid and whether it's because
Roseanne says something racist or
because we invite Clint Eastwood to the
Republican National Convention and he
yells at a chair for 45 minutes we
always end up looking ridiculous and so
maybe we should stop doing this
you
you know maybe maybe it's we should look
at a different strategy here's the
problem
I think we seem to believe and I keep
using the word we I realize I I'm
talking about conservatives generally of
which I guess I am apart although
conservatism is is now such a
meaningless term that I don't even know
how I can associate myself with it but
just for the sake of argument I'm
talking about conservatism generally so
here's the problem we seem to believe
that the way to defeat the left is to
copy it
that's what we're doing where we are
like the pitiful little sad little
little brother you know who sees his
older brother and just imitates starts
dressing like I mean imitates everything
he does and so we treat the left like
our older brothers and so we're just
copying everything they do and then
pretending that we're beating them
somehow that way you see we beat the
left by becoming them haha yes yeah come
in did you
so we see that they have a bunch of
celebrities on their side and we think
that well that means we need to get us
some celebrities but the problem is that
they have cool celebrities on their side
okay they have like LeBron James and we
have Roseanne who isn't even really on
our side
and we have we have Roseanne and we have
I don't know James woods and one of the
Baldwin brothers I think and Scott Baio
okay those are those are our people
I think the Liberals have all the cool
ones and we have this is our collection
of misfits that we that we've that we've
brought together so it doesn't work
we aren't going to beat the left at its
own game we aren't going to out
celebrity them and we should stop trying
now it's it's one thing don't confuse
what I'm saying here because
if we do find a piece of pop culture art
like a film or a television show or
music or whatever that really does
effectively convey a truthful essential
message then we should champion we
shouldn't go overboard we shouldn't
become groupies but we should support it
but roseanne is emphatically not that
show first of all it's just a bad it's a
stupid show second it's it's a vehicle
for left-wing values that's what it's
always been and still is or was anyway
so it's not in any way the kind of thing
that we should be supporting it's not it
this is a vehicle for left-wing values
not for conservative values whatever
those are at this point
on the rare occasion that we get
something like a movie or show that is
that is really different and and and
champions what we might call
conservative values quote unquote then I
think yeah we should support just an
example is my wife and I just a couple
nights ago my wife and I went to see the
movie a quiet place which I think has
and you know it's been out for a while
now it's very popular movie
and I agree with what many other people
have said about the film that even
though on one level it just seems like
your standard sci-fi horror film it
actually I think has some very profound
and beautiful pro-life pro-family Pro
faith themes and on top of that it's
just a well done effective skillfully
crafted and executed film and it's also
entertaining
and so in that case yeah I think we go
support a movie like that a movie that
shows this family bonded together by
faith the man in this protector role the
woman as a strong but feminine character
and you know just a debts that's
something that I think we should support
so I do think that pop culture and
movies and film they are they are very
powerful way to get across a message
um
problem comes when we latch on to
literally any pop-culture property that
even vaguely sort of dimly echoes a few
right wing talking points that's the
problem
we just end up discrediting ourselves
and we come across in the mean time also
like we have horrible taste which I
don't think helps our case either
but the point remains
we are not going to win the culture with
celebrity especially not with these
celebrities okay especially not with
Roseanne but we won't win with with with
celebrity regardless even if we had some
of the cool ones we still would we still
wouldn't win that way
I think we win the culture if it's going
to be won at all
we win it by being radical and firm in
our convictions
we win by being authentic genuine
thoughtful intelligent we win by
sticking to the truth by being adults
okay we don't win by debasing ourselves
by desperately defending whatever racist
crap Roseanne says that's that's not how
we win we don't win anything
we just make ourselves look ridiculous
and we convinced precisely no one what
exactly is being won by by rallying
around Roseanne what what does that
achieve at all
what are we helping who are we
convincing
you
now you might say you might say well
truth and dignity and moral values they
haven't won yet Matt they're losing
so what are you talking about you can't
win that way
yeah they haven't won because so few of
us actually care about those things or
fight for them that's why they haven't
won because we've given up on them we
haven't even tried to fight for them
most of us don't even try to fight but
we've just given up
most of the things you know that when it
comes to being really pro-life and
pro-family and pro marriage most
so-called conservatives have given up on
that they don't even try to fight for it
and then they and then they rationalize
and they reason and they say they say oh
it's because it's a failure it's not
winning well you haven't even tried why
don't you get up and fight first why
don't you give it a shot
before you tell me you can't be done
before you surrender why don't you
actually get up off of your butt and
actually try to fight for these things
don't sit there and tell me that it's
not working or I can't win that way and
let me tell you something if we have
actually gotten to a point in our
culture where truth and morality and
dignity can't win
well then it's done we're finished in
that case and so what's the point
then at that point you may as well
retain your own dignity for yourself and
your family you may as well hold on to
that and worry and and and you know if
everything's collapsing all around us
then you may as well hold on to your own
dignity in your own moral sense
because it's all falling apart anyway
and there's no advantage in just
abandoning that at the last moment
and we also have to ask ourselves you
know what does it mean to win we keep
using this phrase winning winning well
how do we win
um I don't think we win by winning is
not electing Republicans
plenty of Republicans have been elected
over the last many decades and yet the
culture is still on the trajectory that
it's on
I think we win fundamentally by building
a culture that is grounded in objective
truth moral values and faith and
fortified by strong families that's what
it means to win
nuf there's no there's no other winning
that's winning
that can actually be achieved at this
point I don't know
I'm a little bit pessimistic in that
regard but
if I'm gonna if we're gonna go down I'm
gonna go down swinging I don't know
about you
that's what it means to win
that's what we should be fighting for
and the way this ties in to roseanne is
that defending Roseanne and latching on
to Roseanne and these dumb celebrities
that doesn't help advance that cause at
all
in fact it undermines it it hugely
undermines it
especially when you're latching onto
celebrities who for the last many many
many years of their career have only
been contributing to the cultural decay
which is what Roseanne has spent her
entire career doing and is still doing
she is a part of the problem
pray for her yes
but
don't stand in her corner
all right
and there's you know look there's better
shows out there anyway there aren't a
lot of good shows but there are a few
decent ones so maybe watch one of those
and and if there's ever time when we
turn on the TV and there are no good
shows and it's just a bunch of trash
well then we could turn the TV off and
read a book you know that's that's also
an option I think of a very very
worthwhile option as well so thanks for
watching thanks for listening everybody
Godspeed